well as I've said and made some news
about it earlier this year I think that
I hope that people like myself and
others can try to persuade people in the
Republican Party that if you think about
some pretty important issues that we all
believe in whether it's freedom whether
it's frankly the value of community that
that on issues like for example the
freedom to marry the right to marry it's
consistent with the Republican
philosophy to be supportive of two
adults who love what love each other
whether they be gay or straight having
the right to get married I do hope the
Republican Party in the future will
we'll look in the mirror and leaders in
the party will think about where we
stand and say you know what the party of
Lincoln ought to be about letting adults
who love each other to be married and
their party of Lincoln ought to be about
giving people more personal freedom and
the party of Lincoln frankly ought to be
about encouraging the the community that
is built when two people who love each
other decide they're gonna spend their
whole lives together and that requires
people to look in the mirror and it
requires people in the past who haven't
been on their own on that side to think
about where they will want to be on this
issue